les hommes n'ayant pu guérir la mort la
misère l'ignorance écrit Pascal ta vie a
une feuille qui tombait à ce moment-là
tu as vu ce qui s'est passé écrit Pascal
les hommes n'ayant pu guérir la mort la
misère l'ignorance c'est presque un
signe à la Hugo tu sais Hugo dit le
fruit doit tomber la feuille doit tomber
la plume doit s'envoler et au moment où
je te dis ça il y a des gens vont dire
il est devenu cinglé c'est pas faux j'ai
pas dormi il y avait pas de clim donc
j'ai dormi à 44 degrés j'ai jamais vu ça
j'ai essayé de lire Victor Hugo j'étais
ahuri j'étais comme ça et là j'ai fait
interviews je sais plus ce que je dis
mais je sais qu'il y a brut alors vas-y
oh non j'ai pas d'opinion là-dessus
[Musique]
le théâtre
je vais pas vous faire le mec inquiet
impliqué
qui fait des déclarations définitives
comme certains acteurs je vous préviens
moi je vous préviens-moi
non j'ai pas d'opinion j'ai pas
d'opinion ils vont donc ils viennent
tant mieux ils viennent pas Godard
disait ça vous savez on a toujours un
tunisien en bas de chez soi qui vers 23h
peut te dépanner tu vois tu as un
problème tu veux faire un vieux
croque-monsieur il y a quelqu'un dit
mais c'est bon il y a l'arabe qui est
ouvert il y a le Tunisien je te dis
c'est un petit commerçant tout petit bon
marché est fermé ça m'arrêtait de fermer
au champ fermé
et tu vas au petit magasin moi mon
métier c'est l'artisanat montéâtre ma
chaise je peux traverser l'Europe je
peux aller en Amérique je peux attaquer
du Hugo j'ai bien assez vécu puisque
danser dans mes douleurs je marche sans
trouver de bras qui me secourent puisque
je ri à peine aux enfants qui
m'entourent
puisque je ne suis plus réjoui par les
fleurs et ça ça dure 2h30 j'attaque j'ai
besoin d'une chaise donc je suis très
content de faire édu théâtre et du
cinéma mais je vais j'ai pas d'opinion
de sociologue les gens disent le
directeur de CNC a dit que ça revenait
tant mieux est-ce que vous vous de votre
première fois au cinéma les canons de
Navarone place Clichy avec mon père
les canons de Navarone
mais c'est un truc énorme les canons de
Navarone vous rappelez Anthony Quinn les
canons de Navarone c'était le Gaumont
3000 places qui a été remplacé par un
truc d'outillage
mais Castorama Castorama t'imagines
l'époque on avait le pâté le plus grand
cinéma d'Europe c'est devenu Castorama
avec les mecs qui sortent avec des
planches super contents je les admire en
même temps parce que je me dis au sens
pascalien du terme ils ont du bol parce
que tout le but c'est de se divertir tu
comprends voilà Castorama a remplacé
premier film de ma vie avec mon papa les
canons de Navarone c'est l'histoire de
l'attaque de d'Américains qui vont
attaquer un endroit où les Allemands ont
tout pour eux et ils vont les
Allemands c'est merveilleux
oui je crois que je lui ai montré c'est
le seul truc que j'ai fait pas trop mal
je vais montrer tous les githeries
actuellement
la grande aventure pour les êtres
humains pour échapper à la finitude je
veux pas employer des mots à la Pascal
mais ceux qui veulent des enfants
ils veulent des enfants et Niclo a filmé
le bouleversement d'un homme à la
recherche d'une fille début du film il y
a une tragédie il développe pas nique
Luca qui cut tac il y a un drame le fils
meurt on développe pas parce que sinon
là on est là c'est plus 30 000
c'est 2007 entrées par mois par an mais
il fait pas longtemps il fait rapide et
très vite on l'apprend que avant de
mourir malheureusement il a mis en
branle enfin il a mis en branle il a mis
en action un enfant en Belgique quand on
m'a proposé ça c'est un producteur
François crosse qui m'appelle il l'a
bien vendu il m'a dit j'ai un rôle
incroyable pour toi et bizarrement je
l'ai cru je suis peut-être naïf mais je
suis peut-être couillon et je l'ai cru
et puis c'est vrai qu'il parle peu mon
personnage mais c'est pas parce qu'il
parle pas que ça parle pas beaucoup il
arrête pas de parler il dit pas un mot
j'avoue que quand j'ai dit oui je me
suis dit ça c'est du film pour calme
ça c'est du quinzaine de réalisateurs
c'est 33000 anseries sur France c'est
1200 le premier jour sur la France et
sur l'Europe je me suis dit là on va pas
rigoler c'est du niklo c'est une vallée
of love c'est du chef-d'oeuvre d'accord
et je vois le film c'est pas du tout ça
les salles sont pleines le film est
large la seule réalité c'est comme au
théâtre la seule réalité c'est ce qui
viennent le miracle de ceux qui viennent
il y a tout pour qu'ils ne vienne pas il
y a Hidalgo qui fait qu'on peut plus
bouger dans Paris il y a télé 76000
chaînes il y a brut 700 000 programmes
il y a
réunion
échangisme des milliers de possibilités
il y a la pétanque le sport il y a tout
pour ne pas aller au spectacle et
pourtant ils viennent
le fil transmission bien joué est-ce que
pour
pas trop nous emmerder je le tourne
demain 13h30 Pat j'arrive vers midi
éviter j'aurai mal dormi gros
insomniaque je vais y jouer je débarque
je joue avec Kara masrani qui va devenir
Mastroianni parce qu'elle en a marre
qu'on lui dit - Catherine plus Marcello
elle en a pas et elle tombe sur un
acteur que je joue qu'il aime qu'il aime
de manière amicale c'est une histoire
d'amour d'amitié pourquoi je vous dis
tout ça pourquoi je vous dis tout ça
une dernière question c'était un jeune
une jeune qui commence à s'intéresser au
cinéma c'est quoi le film ou les deux
films qu'il faut absolument selon vous
avoir vu parce que sinon on rate cette
cinéphilie et on rate sa vie moi je vais
être très bizarre je vais être très très
bizarre moi qui qui voit bonne chance de
Guy
fais en 13 jours un mec tombe amoureux
d'une meuf de l'ubac et il l'a tout il
l'a filme
moi j'aurais été plus confortable si
vous m'aviez dit dis-nous cinq livres et
comme ça on serait tranquille alors moi
je vous dirai un Flaubert
sans sentimentale le cœur simple surtout
je vous dirai évidemment le Voyage au
bout de la nuit parce que c'est
l'événement majeur du XXe siècle avec
prose et je vous dirai que ils veulent
qu'on s'arrache hein ils en ont marre et
je dirais qu'un grand Guitry c'est
merveilleux que Clouzeau avec Jouvet qui
a des Orfèvres
ça va alors sans les arbits aux jeunes
mais voilà ce que je vous dirai j'ai
beaucoup aimé passer ce moment avec vous
parce que vous êtes comme le film de
nikloo vous parlez peu mais ça parle
merci beaucoup à très bientôt